we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p i
don't know how else to sum up this
voicemail except to say that yall
leftists y'all think y'all awesome that
that's my summary of the voicemail we're
about to listen to all you left us
really driving crazy you know you guys
are all just little little talking heads
on this little youtube y'all think out
like awesome you you people
you guys need to really like grow up
buy yourself a gun shoot it in the air
yep there's an idea stop making
political youtube videos by firearms and
shoot them directly into the air y'all
left us y'all thank y'all awesome that
should be a bumper sticker at some point
maybe it will be we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
what's been going on with the historic
notre-dame Cathedral in paris very very
disturbing sad and the fire is now out
and we will talk about it on the bonus
show there is a new study which suggests
that only 18% say they are paying less
in taxes under trumps tax law but it's
really important to distinguish between
getting a smaller refund and actually
having a reduction or an increase in
your effective tax rates and we will
again dig into that on the bonus show
and we will also talk about a lawsuit to
open safe injection sites in
philadelphia on the basis of religious
freedom which is a new angle that we've
not i don't think we've really talked
about that before in the context of a
harm reduction and safe injection sites
it's an issue i've talked about from our
old home in western massachusetts in
northampton where the david pakman show
started in safe injection sites there
but not something we've talked about in
the context of religious freedom so we
will talk about all of that and more on
today's bonus show two very simple ways
to get access to the bonus show number
one go to www.imtcva.org
go to patreon.com/scishow and make a
pledge of as little as five bucks a
month pledge can be as large as you want
but as little as five dollars a month
and you will also get instant access to
the bonus show I'll speak to you then if
you don't want the David Pakman show to
end for the day then get the bonus show
otherwise I'll be back tomorrow with a
brand new show